ich glaube nicht daran dass die krimen
wieder Ukrainisch wird der erste Punkt
ist dass man über diese territoriale
Frage neu nachdenken muss und der zweite
Punkt ist dass man diese
Selbstverständlichkeit mit der man
annimmt dass die Ukraine komplett im
westlichen Lager landet in der NATO
eines Tages und in der Europäischen
Union dass man das in Frage stellt dass
man also über einen anderen Status der
Ukraine nachdenkt und die verdrehen die
Augen das sind alles Unangenehme
unappetitliche Realitäten die nur zu
ändern wären wenn Russland eine
komplette Niederlage erlaubt die ich mir
wünschen würde die ich aber für
unrealistisch halten